c'est une grosse semaine dans le monde
de la recherche scientifique vous l'avez
vu tout au long de la semaine les prix
nobel qui ont été remis à des chercheurs
en médecine en chimie en physique pas
toujours de facile de comprendre
exactement quelles étaient leurs
recherches mais cette fois ci ce sont
vraiment des découvertes majeures qui
ont changé notre monde et renault munger
a gagné nous résume sa marraine ou
vulgarise aussi bon jour au collège je
vais faire de mon mieux oui c'est ça
merci
commençons donc par les prix qui ont été
remis en chimie des découvertes très
très concrètes à tous les jours pour
nous pouvons effectivement les les prix
nobel ça peut aller souvent dans deux
directions ça peut soit des prix qu'on
donne pour des chercheurs qui ont changé
le domaine très théorique dossier de la
science dans lequel travaillent mais
soit ça peut aller pour des découvertes
qui ont bouleversé le monde dans lequel
on est et chimie c'est vraiment le
meilleur exemple cette année s'était
donné aux américaines django de 9
c'est un hybride ingram et au chercheur
un chercheur japonais qui s'appelle
akira hoshino ont découvert ensemble la
batterie lithium-ion donc c'est la
batterie qu'on retrouve dans tous les
objets électroniques qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui c'est dans nos cellulaires
c'est dans les ordinateurs portables
c'est ce qui fait rouler les voitures
électriques performants cwi zattry
extrêmement performant les batteries
c'est quelque chose que c'est pas
nouveau on en connaissait depuis très
longtemps mais devant le chapiteau
alcalines double à qu'on achète encore
en magasin
c'est une technologie récente mais
celles qui ont la batterie lithium-ion
qu'ils ont inventé ça a énormément
davantage comparativement aux autres
types de batterie ça c'est des batteries
qui sont extrêmement légères pour la
même charge elles sont leurs charges est
beaucoup plus durable et en plus c'est
des batteries qui sont rechargeables
donc ces appareils de ses batteries là
pour les chercheurs pour le comité nobel
ça a bouleversé le monde dans lequel on
est samson n'aurait pas la technologie
qu'on a aujourd'hui nous bien on se
serait pire on aurait pu imaginer essaie
de changer aux batteries double a dans
nos cellulaires à tous les deux jours le
trafic lourd il serait plus longue
qu'ils se consommaient beaucoup plus de
matière ça n'a pas été facile à faire
c'était vingt ans de travail de pôle isa
part de ces trois chercheurs chacun dans
leur coin qui ont amélioré l'invention
l'autre et s'amenait à la première
commercialisation de cette batterie en
1991 et c'est pour ça que les chercheurs
que le prix n'avait le comité nobel lors
les aurait compensé cette semaine a pris
du temps quand même avant qu'ils aient
la récompense
alors que ça fait déjà plusieurs années
c'est toujours comme ça pour les prix en
sciences c'est toujours on attend de
voir si l'invention en elle-même à quel
point c'est un effet sur la société
avant de leur remettre un prix donc
c'est par heure que on donne un prix
nobel à quelqu'un pour quelque chose qui
est arrivé à 30 ans plutôt que 30 ans
plus tôt dans cette ville très bien en
physique est un canadien trois 3
personnes qui ont été récompensés 1 2 ça
a été le canadien james pub au lit il ya
eu deux domaines en fait qui ont été
récompensés en physique et pour ce qui
est pour ce qui est de jean speedball
lui on le récompense et parce que ce
chercheur la kiné au manitoba
on constate que c'est le père de la
cosmologie moderne donc lui son travail
que ça me concentre à lui est
extrêmement théorie par contre c'est
très complexe non pas trop aller là
dedans mais en gros ce que lui a permis
de découvrir c'est en fait il ya des
coups y aurait à regarder l'évolution de
l'univers
la composition de la matière de
l'univers et comment tout ceci a
progressé dans le temps c'est le genre
de choses qui donnent encore des maux de
tête aux astrophysiciens aujourd'hui et
au bout de quelques rit beaucoup plus de
questions que de réponses
mais au moins il ya trouvé qu'ils
avaient ces questions là par contre donc
c'est très théorique est très complexe
par contre pour ce qui est de l'autre
partie du prix de physique a été donné
au suisse michel mayor et didier queloz
ont découvert la première exoplanète
donc ça c'est la première planète en
dehors de notre système solaire qui est
en orbite autour d'une autre étoile
comme le soleil donc cette planète la
première qui ont trouvé en 1995 et lee
sin plein vraiment étrange elle est
assez extrêmes ils ont appelé 51 pegasi
b
c'est pas un nom très poétique mais
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne en
astrophysique imagine planète grosses
comme jupiter mais beaucoup plus près de
son étoile elle en fait le tour en
seulement quatre jours donc une année la
bosse et quatre jours pour nous dans sa
température de surface et 1000 degrés
celsius donc c'est une planète vraiment
extrêmes comme on retrouve pas ici et
depuis cette découverte là les
exoplanètes on sait quelque chose qu'ils
arrêtent pas d'être découvert notre île
4000 jusqu'à maintenant c'est vraiment
un sujet très chaud dans l'astrophysique
et des fois dans trop de ont trouvé
place qui sont semblables à la terre tu
pourrais peut-être abriter la vie donc
ça passe ça fascine beaucoup de gens
alors que d'autres planètes
c'est des choses un peu plus étrange
qu'on le genre de planète étrange qu'on
verrait dans les films comme star wars
historique donc c'est ces chercheurs ont
vraiment montré que l'univers dans
lequel on est beaucoup plus complexe
qu'on le croyait la désinformation
vraiment pertinente sur
l'espace oui c'est ça beaucoup d'oxygène
et de l'application dans les traitements
médicaux oui c'est exactement ça c'est
le prix était donné à deux chercheurs
américains william kelly et greg essensa
et le britannique peter ratliff ont
montré comment les cellules du coeur
gère les niveaux de geiger et réagissent
au niveau d'oxygène donc ça a l'air très
théorique comme ça mais ça a énormément
d'applications en médecine parce que les
niveaux d'oxygène ça déroule sur presque
tous les systèmes du corps sager comment
les vaisseaux sanguins peuvent peuvent
pousser la production de globules rouges
toute l'énergie à l'internaute car peut
être réglé par rapport à ça la produit
par l'exigeant l'énergie du cac
l'oxygène aux dépens de john pour
produire son énergie donc toutes les
cellules vont influencer par ce ca des
effets sur la production des hormones
sur même l'activation de certains gènes
dans notre adn et tous à toutes et tous
ces mécanismes ont énormément de
conséquences dans pour des traitements
médicaux
on ne fait penser des traitements pour
le cancer le cancer utilise beaucoup les
mécanismes mis à l'oxygène pour
accélérer sa croissance
donc si on comprend on s'attaque à ça on
s'attaque aux cancers les maladies
accidents cardiovasculaires ou accidents
cérébrovasculaires tous les leaders et
le cerveau le coeur quand ils ces
accidents laa les dommages commencent à
arriver quand les cellules manque
d'oxygène donc encore prend en
comprenant comment ça fonctionne on peut
aider les personnes qui ont des
indications très tanger exactement ça
donne c'est pour ça qu'on aurait
compensé ces trois chercheurs là parce
que ça avait vraiment rivas a eu des
effets dans tous les domaines de la
médecine
donc encore une fois aucune femme
derrière toulon tu es content il y avait
deux femmes qui ont gagné un prix de
sciences cette année on a eu aucune
c'est pas nouveau depuis le début des
prix nobel a eu seulement vingt femmes
qui ont obtenu un prix en médecine en
chimie et en physique contre 600 hommes
c'est moins de 3% donc c'est vraiment un
chiffre qui qui effrayant on veut
changer le comité nobel veut essayer de
changer les choses mais pour l'instant
est en tout cas surtout en voyant qu'est
ce qui s'est passé cette année sont pas
encore claires quand ces effets le vont
entrer en pratique on verra bien merci
beaucoup
ça fait plaisir merci